Más de la mitad de las mujeres sufren en silencio algún tipo de disfunción sexual.
Cada vez se oye más eso de la brecha del orgasmo.
Es un poco como la brecha salarial pero más embarazoso...
(Risas)
Las mujeres heterosexuales suelen alcanzar el clímax
menos del 60 % de las veces que mantienen relaciones.
Los hombres lo alcanzan el 90 % de las veces.
Para solucionar esto, se ha vendido a las mujeres medicación inadecuada,
cremas de testosterona...
incluso inyecciones genitales que no fueron probadas en ensayos clínicos.
El tema es que la sexualidad femenina no se puede arreglar con una pastilla.
Y eso no es porque esté dañada,
sino mal entendida.
Nuestra cultura ha tenido una imagen sesgada y médicamente incorrecta
de la sexualidad femenina desde hace siglos.
Si más de la mitad de las mujeres tienen algún problema sexual,
quizás nuestra idea de sexualidad no funciona para las mujeres.
Necesitamos entender mejor cómo funcionan las mujeres en verdad.
Soy periodista
y hace poco escribí un libro
sobre la evolución de cómo entendemos la sexualidad femenina.
La sexualidad en sí fue definida cuando los hombres dominaban la ciencia.
Los científicos masculinos veían el cuerpo femenino
a través de sus lentes sesgadas.
Podrían haber preguntado a las mujeres sobre su experiencia.
En vez de eso, investigaron el cuerpo femenino como si fuera algo extraño.
Aún seguimos debatiendo la existencia de la eyaculación femenina y el punto G
como si habláramos de extraterrestres o de ovnis.
"¿De verdad existen?".
(Risas)
Todo esto se duplica en la sexualidad femenina
de las personas LGBTQI,
que ha sido odiada y borrada de maneras muy concretas.
La ignorancia sobre el cuerpo femenino se remonta a siglos.
Se remonta a los comienzos de la medicina moderna.
Retrocedamos al siglo XVI,
una época de revolución científica en Europa.
Los hombres de ideas cuestionaban los dogmas antiguos.
Construían telescopios para mirar las estrellas.
Progresábamos...
a veces.
Lo cierto es que los padres de la anatomía,
y digo "padres" porque, seamos claros, todos eran hombres...
curioseaban entre las piernas de las mujeres
para intentar clasificar lo que veían.
No tenían muy claro qué hacer con el clítoris.
No parecía tener nada que ver con hacer bebés.
El principal anatomista de la época declaró
que probablemente fuera un crecimiento anormal...
(Risas)
y que todas las mujeres que lo tuvieran probablemente fueran hermafroditas.
Se lo consideró tan malo
que a veces los padres mandaban cortar el clítoris a sus hijas
si se lo consideraba demasiado grande.
Es cierto.
Lo que hoy llamamos "mutilación genital femenina"
se practicó en Occidente hasta casi el siglo XX.
Deben preguntarse:
si estaban tan confundidos con el cuerpos femenino,
¿por qué no pedían ayuda a las mujeres?
Pero Uds. deben pensar: "Todo eso es historia.
Ahora el mundo es distinto.
Las mujeres lo tienen todo.
Tienen la píldora anticonceptiva,
tienen el 'sexting', Tinder y la decoración genital".
(Risas)
Las cosas seguro que han mejorado.
Pero la ignorancia médica sobre el cuerpo femenino continúa.
¿Cuantos de Uds. reconocen esto?
Es la estructura completa del clítoris.
Lo vemos como una protuberancia del tamaño de un guisante,
pero la verdad es que se extiende hacia el interior del cuerpo.
La mayor parte está debajo de la piel.
Contiene casi tanto tejido eréctil como el pene.
Es precioso, ¿verdad?
Se parece un poco a un cisne.
(Risas)
Esta escultura es de una artista llamada Sophia Wallace,
parte de su proyecto "Cliteracy".
(Risas)
Ella cree que necesitamos saber más sobre el clítoris
y es verdad si tenemos en cuenta que esta estructura
fue mapeada completamente en 3D por investigadores recién en 2009.
Esto fue después de terminar de mapear todo el genoma humano.
(Risas)
Esta ignorancia tiene consecuencias en la vida real.
En 2005, en una revista médica,
la Dra. Helen O'Connel, uróloga,
advirtió a sus compañeros que esa estructura aún no se encontraba
en publicaciones médicas básicas...
libros de texto como "Anatomía de Grey".
Esto podría traer graves consecuencias en una cirugía.
Procésenlo.
Caballeros:
imaginen que corrieran el riesgo de perder el pene
porque los médicos no tuvieran muy claro dónde está
o qué aspecto tiene.
Como es de esperar,
muchas mujeres tampoco tienen claro cómo es su propia anatomía genital.
Y no se las puede culpar.
A menudo, el clítoris también falta en los esquemas de educación sexual.
Las mujeres perciben
que la cultura ve sus cuerpos con dudas, en el mejor de los casos
y, en el peor, con desdén y asco.
Muchas mujeres todavía ven sus genitales como algo sucio o inadecuado.
Hay una tendencia cada vez mayor a comparan sus vulvas
con las pequeñitas y limpias que ven en la pornografía.
Por eso el negocio de la labiaplastia se ha vuelto tan popular
entre mujeres y adolescentes.
Algunos lo consideran un tema trivial.
Cuando estaba escribiendo mi libro, fui a una cena
y alguien dijo: "¿La sexualidad no es un problema del primer mundo?
¿No lidian las mujeres con problemas más importantes en el mundo?".
Claro que sí.
Pero creo que el impulso de trivializar el sexo es parte del problema.
Vivimos en una cultura que parece obsesionada con el sexo.
Lo usamos para vender de todo.
Decimos a las mujeres que ser sexis
es una de las cosas más importantes que pueden hacer.
Pero lo que realmente hacemos es menospreciar el sexo.
Lo reducimos a una triste sombra de lo que es en realidad.
El sexo es más que un acto.
Hablé con la Dra. Lori Brotto,
una psicóloga que trata problemas sexuales en las mujeres,
incluidas las supervivientes de un trauma.
Dice que cientos de sus pacientes tienden a repetir lo mismo.
Dicen: "No me siento completa".
Sienten que han perdido la conexión con sus parejas y con ellas mismas.
¿Qué es el sexo, entonces?
Tradicionalmente, hemos definido el acto sexual
como un proceso lineal orientado a un objetivo.
Es algo que empieza con el deseo,
sigue con las caricias eróticas
y termina con un final feliz.
Excepto que muchas mujeres no lo experimentan así.
Para ellas es menos lineal y más circular.
Este es un modelo nuevo de la excitación y el deseo femenino
desarrollado por la Dra. Rosemary Basson.
Dice muchas cosas,
incluso que las mujeres pueden empezar un encuentro por muchas razones distintas
que no son el deseo,
como la curiosidad.
Pueden acabar con un clímax o con varios,
o con satisfacción sin ningún tipo de clímax.
Todas las opciones son normales.
Algunos están empezando a defender una definición más rica de la sexualidad.
Tanto si se identifican como hombre, mujer o ningún género,
el sexo gira en torno a nuestra relación con los sentidos.
Se trata de ir más despacio,
escuchar al cuerpo,
estar en el momento presente.
Se trata de nuestra salud y bienestar en un sentido holístico.
En otras palabras,
el sexo, en su verdadera dimensión, no es profano.
Es sagrado.
Por eso, las mujeres están redefiniendo su sexualidad.
Se preguntan: ¿qué es para mí el sexo?
Están experimentando con prácticas menos orientadas hacia un final feliz,
y más al sentirse completas.
Así que están probando con clases de sexo espiritual,
talleres de masturbación...
incluso filmando su propia porno
que celebra la diversidad de los cuerpos reales.
Para quien aún piense que es un asunto trivial, considere esto:
entender el propio cuerpo es crucial para el importante tema
de la educación sexual y el consentimiento.
Saber de manera íntima y profunda qué clase de caricia nos agrada,
qué presión, qué velocidad, qué contexto,
hace que se sepamos mejor qué tipo de caricia no nos gusta
y tengamos la confianza para decirlo.
En el fondo, no se trata de que las mujeres practiquen más sexo o mejor,
ni de que las mujeres tengan tantos orgasmos como los hombres.
Se trata de aceptarse a sí mismas y a su propia experiencia única,
de ser expertas del propio cuerpo.
Es definir el placer y la satisfacción bajo sus propios términos.
Y si eso significa que son felices sin practicar sexo,
también es perfecto.
Definir el sexo como parte de nuestra salud y bienestar
y empoderar a las mujeres para adueñarse de él
es el siguiente paso crucial hacia la igualdad.
Y creo que sería un mundo mejor no solo para las mujeres,
sino para todos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)